all right you are coming to us uh Terry
from uh a gym and I'm told it's a boxing
gym this is your gym
yes my team boxing gym yeah yeah and I
can see it behind you very impressive
looks very much like a gym where one
would box
um say your story so far checks out you
get an A yeah do you teach boxing and
you're also a promoter of fights is that
correct yes I do um I've been doing that
for quite a while the promotions but but
I trained Fighters and run a gym it's
it's an interesting uh career and it's
called Buckhead Fight Club is this uh
Buckhead in Georgia
yeah it's kind of like the Atlanta
Financial District we're also on an area
that's really diverse
um so we got all the great ethnic foods
here plus all the money terrific
you've thought this all thought this all
out I know Atlanta bit because for many
years I worked for Turner based in
Atlanta oh yeah and I did some shows in
Atlanta and really loved that City it's
uh it's new it's an amazing Place
incredible place now tell me uh I'm kind
of interested because I I don't know
much about fighting but I'm curious
about it I know it's an amazing exercise
I mean if you're really boxing you
exhaust yourself in about I do in about
30 seconds it's an incredibly tough
workout it's a full body workout but
also I like the idea of learning the
science of boxing is that something you
think you could teach me
oh yeah for sure definitely talk to me
about it's a science internet okay you
can talk to me about what do you need to
know about me uh to know about my
potential as a boxer
well you're already tall which which
definitely helps why does that help
people that are really tall
um well it's kind of like if you're
playing baseball and you got a little
bitty short bed or you got a long bat
you know the ball is going to go further
with a with a long batch yeah yeah so it
actually has more power
um some tall people are slow though but
I don't think you're slow no no I've got
very fast twitch muscles everything
about me yes that's right fast quick uh
and so I think I would have a a quick
powerful punch oh that makes it hard
yeah that makes it a Hard Punch now what
about a hand-eye coordination is that
important
it is important well this is over
the conversation is done it's been nice
talking to you no so hand-eye
coordination very important uh I could I
could probably develop that I could get
better at it
um yeah and then candy crush or
something yeah
Montage where he wakes up
looks an egg into a glass and eats it
and then goes and plays Candy Crush to
the same music right and then he's
playing candy crushes he slowly goes up
the step perhaps to that museum or
library in Philadelphia you know my life
has changed so much Sona has it yeah let
me tell you how I can just get all this
stuff delivered right to my door I mean
if you grew up when I did in the early
1920s that was unheard of you know a kid
in a cap you had to hey boy boy you know
and you'd have to say yes sir and you'd
have to say you know toss him a coin go
get me that goose in the window and he'd
say yes sir Mr Scrooge but it was that
was was like back then yeah but now it's
not so much of our world digitized an
automated why stick to Old School
mailing and shipping if you mail or ship
often let stamps.com do the hard part
for you simply print Postage and
shipping labels right from your home or
office it's ready to go in minutes no
long lines are complicated setup
required it's the easiest so the best
yeah postage rates just increased again
hello luckilystamps.com has the best
discounts in the industry avoid the
hassle and get started with stamps.com
today sign up at 7 dot com slash Conan
for a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
free digital scale no long-term
commitments or contracts just go to
stamps.com Conan so uh what else I mean
I've got uh I've got some muscle mass on
me and I can put on some I can put on
some muscle well we say unboxing you
know never judge a book by its cover so
you can have all the muscle in the world
and you can be horrible or you can have
no muscle and be amazing so it really
doesn't matter about the muscle but if
you have some Skies
out there you're in good shape you know
usually when people look at me and say
well don't judge a book by its cover I
get insulted but I'm deciding not to now
I'm deciding to take that as a
compliment
um that's a compliment yeah how long
would it take me to learn to be a pretty
decent fighter do you think
uh how old are you now I just turned it
takes a little time I just turned six
yeah okay I would probably give it
a few years yeah well I only have I only
have I only have a few here he's 64.
before he even knows how to buy you know
nowadays I mean boxing's changed so much
you got Jake Paul and and Tick Tock
Fighters and now there's a thing where
you can just slap somebody you know
there's like a sport they just slap them
and it's really knock them out I want to
I just want to slap people and I want it
to be I want to be slappy people I want
to slap people but they can't slap me
back I'm just slapping at them and then
I want to be like a 17th century Dandy
with the white clothes
exactly Terry I want to have some gloves
that I take off and I slap them with the
gloves yeah and then my henchmen and
bodyguards move in and I'm protected you
want to um challenge people to a duel
but then never have to do it yes yeah
thank you right right
um I also want to do the old pieces
oh yeah that's the best yeah
anyway effective how come that went away
why did that go away yeah why did that
old time I did it in an SNL sketch once
I was obsessed with yeah old I feel like
this and so what is what was is that a
if a modern box if a modern boxer went
into the ring and thought Floyd
Mayweather and and was using that style
what would happen uh he would probably
not last too long but you know what
that's from is like boxing used to be
different
um especially in Europe they would do
like Point scoring so it wasn't about
knocking people out it was about how
many points you could like so that's how
they would box you know about touching
him yeah I had a Hungarian fighter one
time who told me he had like a thousand
amateur fights I'm like I would be dead
by now but he said no Mike Tyson ruined
boxing uh you know with with all the
power shots and knocking people out it's
the Americans we kind of changed it
honestly but before that it was like you
could box like that oh yeah no before
Mike Tyson came along I was feared
and then he came along and
changed everything